hey youtubers is Charlie what was that
that was like the craziest episode ever
I think musikmeister is the most
powerful character in the DC Universe
now there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway going on now - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video that has
special significance given what happened
at the end of the episode
so the basic pitch if you were like
totally confused about why this episode
existed why they decided to do it as a
musical it was just meant to be a fun
way to lighten up the characters who
were super bummed out based on what was
happening on both of their shows
so Supergirl got all this crap that just
got dumped on her the same thing
happened to Barry so by his own
explanation music Meister came in to
help them out and I think that he is now
the most powerful character that we've
ever seen on the shows he's like the god
of the DC Universe so I'll explain how
his powers work and why it is that he's
so powerful but top 10 WTF and Easter
eggs so number 10 Barry with his mother
flashback always gets you when you see
her she talks about singing in the rain
how musicals singing help you be your
true self it has sort of sticks with
Barry for the rest of the episode and
they have this nice transition where
he's slumped on Cisco's couch remember
he and iris broke up so he's been living
with Cisco just being a complete bum
watching singing in the rain over and
over again driving Cisco crazy then they
get to call number nine Martian
Manhunter and Montel brings Supergirl to
earth one so if you didn't watch the
first part of the crossover on Supergirl
at the end of the last Supergirl
episodes they have him in Chains but he
puts the whammy on Cara sucks her powers
out and uses them to escape to earth one
where he says he's looking for the
fastest man alive so they just take it
to mean that he's going after the flash
so one they need their help because
they're like hey we have a metahuman
attack here maybe you can help get car
out of this state and Barry's in danger
so the funny thing about this is that
you know you talk about characters being
overpowered musikmeister is the most
Opie character ever Martian Manhunter
gets a lot of those complaints from
writers he is a super powerful character
and it's a bit of a problem for the TV
show because he should be able to do all
the things the car can do by himself but
in addition he has all those extra
powers on top of it he can shape-shift
he can phase through things so it's kind
of funny if you're having an argument
about who's the most Opie character on
all these television shows the most Opie
hero that we have
now is these our musikmeister if you
think that he's good or martian
manhunter I would say Martian Manhunter
because musikmeister seems like more of
a trickster mr. Mitzvah pixel style so
we'll talk about him in a second because
he's a completely different character
but number 8 music Meister vs. both of
the Flash's he takes them down instantly
using Cara strength and I love the way
they use powers in this episode the big
team-up effort later was almost better
than the big four and I crossover with
the way they use their powers together
so Kid Flash gets his ass handed to him
Barry gets his ass handed to him and
he's now in the dream state with Cara
and I love this hilarious Simpsons style
get confident stupid approach to making
Wally feel better about himself like he
has to put him down like oh you're not
feeling good Kid Flash didn't do so hot
on the Speed Force in order to get him
to feel better about himself which is
the worst idea ever it's all about to go
Wally into that fight later in the
episode but if you haven't noticed
they've actually changed a lot about the
look of Wally West's costume so his
haircut is different it sticks up the
top a little bit more they shave the
sides down and they made him a new mask
that fits his face a little bit better
than the ones that he originally wore at
the beginning of season 3 so it just
looks a little bit better it is that all
through the first season with grant
gustin's version of the costume and they
make a new version of the cow every
single season so number seven Barry
wakes up in the matrix that he's created
for himself if the lounge and Supergirl
is singing Moon River but she doesn't
seem like she completely realizes what's
going on like she just wakes up in the
middle of the song like you see her eyes
darting around like why am i singing
what the hell is going on here and it is
they're sort of figuring things out and
joking about their terrible
relationships there's actually a poster
behind here it's kind of an Easter Egg
for abracadabra next week because it's
the magician but this is also a magician
in real life so I'm not like a super
musical buff but I'm sure if you look in
the background on a lot of these shots
if you're a big theatre person or you
knew a lot of these songs there's like
an extra level of Easter eggs here but
all the songs they pick the whole point
of the episode was just to give them the
reaffirmation to get them through the
rest of the season like Barry needs to
be on his a game to fights avatar
Supergirl needs to be on her a game too
in all the songs they sang all the
advice that they gave to the other
characters that were in there like the
iris character and the mono character
they were giving advice that they needed
to be
to themselves number six all the other
characters we meet Merlin he's one of
the mob bosses Joe is the other mob boss
with Martin Stein they're sort of a team
together against Merlin but they're just
rival factions and it becomes this West
Side Story thing whereby they go to war
over their children but like Cisco is a
bartender who has dreams of being
something more when is the piano player
but music Meister comes in and it
explains what the rules are they have to
follow the script and solve sort of like
this overarching mystery like they have
to bring those rival factions together
over their children and stop it from
happening
otherwise they're going to die in there
but you start to learn about how his
powers work so he's reading their mind
because he's connected to them so that's
how he has access to all their memories
that's how we knew about Wally West's
confidence being shaken because he was
still tapped to Barry's mind so he knew
everything to Barry everything that Cara
knew the twist at the end of the episode
almost seemed like a crumpled that idea
up and threw it away because he almost
sounds like he's omniscient so he really
does have godlike powers but we can talk
about that in a second number five this
is sort of a hilarious twist we find out
that Milly Iris's character is in love
with Mon L who was Merlin's son in his
name Tommy which is a big easter egg for
Tommy from arrow because in real life at
least in the context of the show
Merlin's son's name is Tommy so it's
almost like the shows really want to
have Colin Donal back on but they can't
so they just keep referencing him every
chance they get you just hear about
Tommy on every single show it's crazy
favorite reaction in the episode hands
down was Cara almost throwing up at the
sight of them together that is going to
be my go-to reaction gift from now on
we're in love Oh
[Music]
number four we get to the point where
they actually have to perform an
original song that was one of Merlin's
instructions is that none of his crap I
want you to come up with something
original so the song they sang was
superfriend so that was a big easter egg
for the cartoon show
[Music]
matter of fact been working on something
all day things really are easier in
musical all right Barry makes fun of
Superman and makes a really big flash
pun but there were a bunch of flash
punch through the episode got there in
time you can just go back in time I give
it another shot I'm actually not
supposed to do that anymore
you go to hell you're taking both of us
there now who's the villain flash
one of the Flash's greatest powers from
the comics is making crazy flash puns
there were also a whole bunch of running
metaphors in the songs he's saying
number three was when the dads were
singing to their children I actually had
to look the song up most of the songs I
didn't recognize right away I had to
like go look up real quick
so that was Guys and Dolls it was this
really heartfelt song but I loved the
twist at the end where Merlin was like
you know totally happy that you're in
love this is great he gives him that
really heartfelt speech then turns on a
dime and says oh we're still going to
war I'm gonna kill them all get the boys
we are going to war so what you want to
do gather up the boys go on the war so
number two was the big team up versus
music Meister so this was hands-down the
best use of team-up powers that they've
ever had on the show at least as good if
not better just in the way Cisco has
gotten more sophisticated with the way
he's used his portal ability music
Meister has both the powers of the flash
and Supergirl so he raises Wally around
but then Cisco portals Martian Manhunter
to take him down while portaling Wally
to another location so they can
double-team it totally works but the
funny thing is is at the end of the
episode he explains that it was all just
to boost their confidence so he lets
them beat him and then sort of banishes
himself away so number one they finally
make it out iris and Montel are able to
save them it's a very classic movie
storybook type ending where they kiss
them and bring them back to the real
world like Sleeping Beauty or something
like that they all joke about Barry
being a good singer Caitlin's like I
totally know and she's referencing the
karaoke episode I've heard Barry sing
and then Barry sings the Stevie Wonder
song to Iris and asked her to marry him
again so everything seems like it's back
to normal we're getting to abracadabra
next week but music Meister we have to
talk about how crazy this character is
so Darren Criss did a good enough job
with the way they wrote him he was just
meant to be this silly guest star maybe
he'll come back on in the future
but he is like the god of the DC TV
universe now he banishes on command so
he seems like mr. Mitchell pixel
somebody who has powers that you can't
really define like he can manifest
almost any power he can think of he's
almost like you from Star Trek that's
how powerful he is so this is what his
ability looks like
thanks to mr. Mitchell pixel from
Supergirl so you know there are two
different characters
[Music]
darling who the hell are you my name is
mister missus Petaling are you from
another birth multiverse universe
something yeah you wouldn't understand
where I come from where I'm sorry that's
it you're just gonna keep somebody else
a lesson
that's exactly I'm gonna do Oh drink of
your fellow man lending a helping hand
put in love in your heart so let me know
in the comment what do you think about
all this and how powerful do you think
that he is you've got to be more
powerful than any other character so
that's usually a notice that they're not
going to come back very soon but what's
going to happen next is I'll post my
abracadabra a trailer video tomorrow
there's a brand new character they just
cast who's actually going to be set in
the future like a future scientist that
works with Barry when he goes to the
future so I'll explain who she is when I
post that video but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Katherine ban
why please private message me on the
back end of my channel there was a new
round that started in this video
announce the winner when I post that
trailer video tomorrow where you wait
for that click here to learn all about
the season 4 flash villain and you can
click here for my Power Rangers
non-spoilery review thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys in the next video
you